this is a production of Cornell
University
Tim Sweeney who is a policy analyst and
works 150 percent for Ag and markets
under percent of that on half than 50%
on his real job so Tim is just going to
give us a little overview of their
current regulatory status from the Agra
markets perspective and then I'm sure
he'd be happy to take all of your
questions so I just want to start off
with a little background on the program
as many of you probably know the 2014
federal farm bill was what was the law
that allowed us to begin this whole
adventure in the first place and
subsequently now that 2018 farm bill has
expanded the program and changed it
somewhat whereas hemp is no longer
controlled substance federally however
until we have guidelines from the
federal government from the USDA in
particular we are continuing to operate
under the 2014 program guidelines so you
need to keep that in mind that it is not
yet a fully free market out there you
still need to register with the state
and you will even after the 2018 program
is fully enforced that's part of part of
the requirements of the federal farm
bill so that the farm bill requires that
the USDA now take charge of industrial
hemp and takes it out of the realm of
the DEA as it's no longer controlled
substance I should say as an aside
though New York law has not quite caught
up yet so technically have is still a
controlled substance in New York State
but they're working on fixing that so
the USDA now is in is in the process of
establishing their regulations to run
the hemp program for the entire nation
once their regs come out once their
program guidelines come out each state
that wants to hope wants to host a
program will have to apply to the USDA
the USDA will have to approve the state
program and after that we will do
rulemaking in New York State which will
then for those of you who are in the
program you're familiar with the
research partner agreements we expect
that the requirements to have those will
go away and we'll be running the program
pursuant to regulations but for now all
of those requirements for the research
partner agreements remain in force and
and the 2014 farm bill remains in force
one exception that any of you who wanted
to get seed in the past from a foreign
source know what you had to go through
with us for that we had to apply to the
DEA to get an import permit they would
then send the paperwork back to me I
would send your permit to you the seed
would have to be delivered to our office
in Albany and then you'd have to come
and get it that is all gone away now as
the DEA is no longer requirement and
will not issue any import permits early
on this year that there was kind of a
bit of confusion where the the DEA said
we're not issuing permits and the
government in Canada said well we're not
sending seed to the US without a permit
so we were kind of in a tough spot there
but we finally worked all of that out
there are no longer any DEA permits
required and you do not have to come to
Albany to pick up your seed any more it
can be delivered directly to you and any
of you that had the misfortune of having
to come to our office to get the seed
will appreciate how big a deal that is
so over the years since the 2014 farm
bill started this all off 2016 was our
first year that we had a crop in the
ground in New York State the program has
grown like crazy since then I think
we're up to just over 500 growers now
and that represents about 18,000 acres
approved for growing in New York State
about 75% of that a question was asked
in the morning session how much the the
acreage is devoted to CBD about 75% and
CBD it would be a good guess I think
we're currently taking applications for
growing for fiber grain and CBD we're
currently taking applications for
processing a fiber and grain we are not
however accepting any applications right
now for processing CBD and we don't know
when that will open up again I expect it
will but I really have no idea when that
would be
okay with regard to CBD CBD and food
according to the FDA and the FDA still
has oversight over CBD that was pretty
clear in the federal farm bill that
nothing in the farm bill undid FDA law
and so as far as the FDA is concerned
you cannot add CBD to food and you
cannot sell CBD as a dietary supplement
New York State we have a different
approach
you can add CBD to products that look
like food if those products are made as
a dietary supplement in a GMP facility
and following all the Code of Federal
Regulations sections that apply to
dietary supplements the product would
then have to be labeled as a dietary
supplement marketed as a dietary
supplement and sold as a dietary
supplement so we are a little bit
different than some other states in that
regard but we do allow CBD in in those
products does anyone have any questions
so far
I think I'm pretty much pretty much
cover about everything that I needed to
tell you for now the application process
remains the same you apply to us it's
still a five hundred dollar fee it's a
three year application a three year
license that you would be granted you
would go through the process of having
to do the research partner game and
having that notarized and returned to us
you would need to still be sampled you
know 21 days prior to when you want to
harvest you contact us we will send a
horticultural inspector out you have to
fill out what's called a harvest report
form with us our horticulture inspectors
look about they'll sample your crop send
the sample back to our food lab to do
the regulatory test and then you'd be
good to go if your crop is is within
legal limits within 21 days so you you
apply to us you send in the harvest
report form which is more like a harvest
request that sort of a misnomer so it's
a harvest request form so within 21 days
of one you want to harvest is when you
should send that form to us so and then
we will do our best to get an inspector
I think they're shooting for within a
week yeah two to three days been my day
to day two to three days Larry says it's
been his experience
that is not within the purview of our
program so we have told people that if
they are selling a product that the FDA
considers illegal they're definitely in
a you know they could be in a bind there
and and it's there's somewhat of a gray
area as to what is allowed and what
isn't allowed but some of it's very
plain and the FDA if they choose to
enforce they could take enforcement
action you cannot sell any raw flour in
New York State to anyone outside and you
can make any products in New York
obviously so you're talking about when
the USDA issues their program expect to
come out with state as soon as possible
as the answer and I know that's not a
great answer we are i I spoke with the
woman who runs the egg marketing
services section at the USDA in their
test with developing the program and she
said that they are on track for early
fall release of the USDA program guide
right so then we will do everything in
our power to get our program submitted
to them and a timely fashion and get it
back out I would certainly hope that we
would be running under the new program
for next growing season but we don't
know there's a lot of there's a lot of
variables in
did you say together no you heard it
right okay the question was whether or
not CBD smokeable flower is allowed in
New York State it is not we do not in
our program you cannot sell raw flower
to anyone outside the program and it
cannot do any smokeable or available
products they're not in our program or
they're violating their program
agreement with us and if that's the case
then they could be expelled from the
program
right
I don't want to speculate on legislation
that has a you know it hasn't passed it
and may may actually look a lot
different than the old legislation we
don't I don't know what it would look
like but that is the model that was in
the previous legislation was that cvd
would be would be under that new
authority
[Music]
[Music]
in order for it to be industrial hemp it
has to be point three or below THC so I
I don't know what the legislation if any
would look like I don't know what that
if they would write something in the law
that would address that however I will
say that the federal level is point
three and we're going to be held to the
federal standard to get our so we have a
sampling protocol for the top ten
centimeters of the plant and one that
we're we're trying to be consistent with
what other states do as well so that
there wouldn't be any situation where
New York State products might have some
taint to them as with regard to
interstate transportation if we weren't
held to the same standard as other
people
so the question the question is with
regard to some marijuana plants that are
showing up in fields that are planted to
some other crop or to him so it does so
basically saying what's the possibility
of having unlicensed growers is that
where you're asking I think you're one
are you wondering about
there's no regulation that would would
address that are you worried about it if
your field tested hot because of that
crop I would write so I would hope that
the randomness of our sampling protocol
would take that worry away if that
wasn't the case and if it was a special
circumstance that you could prove that
you there was some renegade crop growing
there we could probably take a look at
that have our inspectors come back out
and see exactly what's going on there
until it falls into law enforcement says
right yeah do you do that will you have
a published procedure for how you will
handle a non-compliant test and what
will be the steps that you or law
enforcement will take after that
non-compliant test the second test will
law enforcement be brought to the field
what's gonna happen
Larry always has to do this to me yes
question I don't know the answer to that
procedure that policy has not yet been
established but I we are going to have
to come up with a disruption policy it
is not our intention to be law
enforcement there or take the place of
law enforcement jurisdiction if somebody
in our program ends up with a field
that's hot we will work with them to
destroy the crop and we will not our
first call is not going to be to law
enforcement to get them jammed up in a
legal proceeding we want we want this
program to succeed we want our program
participants to succeed so we'll do
everything we can within within the law
and you know we you have to keep in mind
that we're going to have the federal
government looking at us to make sure
that we're doing everything we need to
do to stay compliant with what their
requirements okay thanks a lot Tim
[Applause]
like this if you guys want to follow
along it's a little bit different than
some of the other camp handouts because
the entire first page is about the
weather so I'm sure there's a lot of
growers from different not just hemp in
the group and we've had a couple rough
years the last two 2017 was the first
time we got an actual spring planting of
her and it was wet it was a wet spring
we planted late in some of our locations
we had lots of Pythium so he lost a lot
of seedlings to that and then it sort of
turned into like this beautiful summer
so all of our seedlings that survived
the Pythia grew beautifully we had
amazing yields I've looked at other
trials from around the country and it
was just like yeah we can we can
definitely grow hemp for grain and fiber
in New York we can do this and then we
had a beautiful long dry warm fall so
everything got harvested it was it was
nice it was really nice our highest
yielding cultivar for green was over a
ton per acre and then our grains are our
fiber yields were also really high so we
were had six and a half dry tons per
acre ones are our biomass produced and
that was in 72 days so that that's
enormous and then we had last year
again again we've had a pretty wet
spring so he planted a little bit later
than we had hoped and then finally
things dried out enough to plant and it
was like someone could turn the faucet
off like we had five to six weeks of
just drought so we had pretty poor
seedling stands and then in addition to
that because of the drought we had a bus
like stunting the plants were just
stunted it was we were watching it you
know watching it like you can do it plan
we're little cheerleaders and and we
thought we'd might be okay because the
wheat it was driving up if the weeds
weren't growing either and then the rain
started coming like everyone prayed way
too hard for rain last summer but I
think that was the key because once it
started it didn't stop until this spring
and the weeds out through all of our
shorter varieties it just didn't stop
raining and so we had some big disease
pressure later on in the season our
grain yields were half that of what they
were the year before the fiber yields
weren't impacted nearly as much but but
they were still four and a half tons
verses six and a half times four and a
half tons of still a lot of forage to
earth a biomass to produce in 75 days
but but no it just still wasn't because
of
Stan's burn is good to start out with
wasn't as good as than the year before
and then our grains yields were at last
about half as much so there's a nice
graph on the back so we're for this data
we had 13 grain varieties in 2017 but we
and then for fiber types we also have
the four fiber types in 2018 but we
added to it so we ended up having closer
to 25 grain and dual-purpose type but I
didn't include that information in here
because I just wanted to compare you
know the same varieties in both years
but I think the big difference that we
saw in the grain that wheat harvested
was the Fusarium on the grain that going
to talk about that too much
gary will be up here in a little bit but
so there was detectable vomitoxin in
some of our trials so especially trials
that were in locations around areas for
a lot of other feet and barley and oats
are produced those ones have very high
levels we had our highest detectable
level of vomitoxin is 36.6 parts per
million on some of our hemp so that
that's a lot right I think the cutoff
for food is 1 to 2 per 2 parts per
million depending on what the main
is going to be and so you know looking
at the screen and seeing 36 biggest
ticks parts-per-million was a shock for
sure the other other quality components
of the brain were different as well so
in 2017 it was close to 36 percent oil
in the seeds and it was less it was 129
percent in 2018 so there's a big drop
there as well and just you could you
could look at the grain and see it was
not of the right quality it was
weathered looking there's lots more
throw a few pieces you can see
discoloration from the disease although
so in my head in my head we had one
awesome year which can show the
potential like New York can do this
we've got the potential the seed the
seed sources are there and then the next
year was just like whoa we're gonna need
some more tools and if we're gonna be
able to manage this and really keep this
going as a crop
restaurants
all of our all of our certified law
feedlots were fine or THC nothing came
in first person
[Music]
yeah he was asking at the Fusarium was a
blue in from the neighboring fields and
that is very likely the chance last year
was a really bad year for Fusarium on
all of his small grains and corn and him
it was all over just a really bad year
for Fusarium Thank You Jamie
thirty thousand just going to give a
quick update on our breeding program
here yeah so these cultivar trials are
really good at informing New York
farmers but they also informed readers
like me our breeding program this
Vermont primarily focused on developing
disease resistant high yielding
varieties with decent no oil and protein
content and diverse cannabinoid profiles
so we make selections from some of these
cultivars that we've tested in the field
so we've been doing this for the past
like three years this year we identified
a subset of high yielding dual-purpose
goal cars that have good grain yield
along with good candidate Kenan
cannabinoid profiles so what we did is
we took seed Lots from these particular
varieties and grew them out and see
flats and we made early selections at
the seedling stage based on plant
seedling bigger or height lack of
disease and then from there we are using
high-throughput molecular markers to
first identify a cannabinoid type or
hemp type or marrow or marijuana type so
we can create progeny that are
homozygous M type so we want to make we
want to make hemp populations we don't
want to make hemp marijuana populations
we saw that a lot of these coke bars
from the last couple of years have been
segregating for ham and marijuana type
so if you want to talk to Jacob he's in
our lab he talked a little bit about
that earlier if you want to talk to me
about that more Jacob more just can't
ask us but so what we do is we're
screening these plants for a cannabinoid
type and then what we want to do is
select from that subset a percentage of
females and a percentage of males that
are have type and then we'll bring in
hemp type females into greenhouse ranges
you know different varieties of piece
have females and introduce them into us
introduce them to a single male cultivar
that we've also screened and from from
there we bulk those seeds and we'll you
know we'll book those seeds clean it and
plant it out in the field this year we
planted out I think ten crosses and
we're still working on some more in the
greenhouse we've also done some
feminized populations that we're doing
selections on so from there we'll make
selections in the field so we don't make
selections in the field bring them into
the greenhouse and use those for our
future crosses so the big you know we so
we don't have to really rely on
isolation you know so we don't have to
fear pollen in the field
we're actually wanting to go out do some
cultivar
evaluations in the field all in one big
field instead of isolated blocks you
know three miles apart from one another
it's just you just don't have the tools
to do that right now
so we've also we've also evaluated
different feral populations from
Wisconsin Illinois Nebraska and some New
York feral populations as well as
different feminized populations and
dioecious populations of varying
pedigrees so it'd be interesting to see
what kind of traits we we can garner
from those populations so again like
Larry said we're doing genotyping just
to look at the genetic diversity of the
plants that New York farmers are
planting on the state we've done this
for a year we have well we have two
plates of GPS or it's genotyping by
sequencing it's a different it's our
genotyping method but we're going to
submit another plate soon so if you're
interested in getting your plants that
you're growing how that genotyped it
won't be it there won't be any cost to
you we just will visit your field
collect your sample from your plan and
then we'll share it with you you know we
want to be as open as possible in our
breeding program and our genotyping
program and we'll offer that and it will
throw that up online so you can see
where your plants set in the entire you
know what was that the galaxy of your of
our genetic diversity that we see here
well yeah just come up and talk to me if
you want to do that I've got a sign-up
sheet and if you know your cultivars
offhand you can just write those down
thank you so let me just give the just
the two second summary of what we've
learned so far and we haven't gotten our
second set of 95 samples back not every
variety is named according to its
genetic makeup
so sometimes names don't match genetics
and that can be interesting and also
that we do see groupings of different
cultivars into distinct genetic groups
so we would like to expand that analysis
with another 95 samples so if you're
interested in doing that please let us
know thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
so certainly with a new crop on the
landscape the risk of diseases is
eminent and we're very fortunate to have
Gary Bergstrom here to talk about the
surveys and the characterizations
they've done the diseases so far yep
hello everybody so I'd like to start out
by acknowledging two people in my lab
that are really at the at the forefront
of our diagnostic effort gen star Kevin
Meyers would you stand up there and and
all three of us will be around and I
would love to visit with you about
things that you think may be diseases
that you're seeing in your fields but
where I think we will all agree we're
still learning a lot and this is the
third year of our effort to try to in
surveillance to try to find out what's
going on in in commercial fields of hemp
as well as in some of the kind of
variety trials that you've seen here
today and if you noticed it was by and
large pretty clean we found that little
bit of pottery mildew we did collect a
few very minor leaf spots and you may
have noticed a few plants showing will
owing wilting on one side of the plant I
think there's some Fusarium wilt and in
a relatively few plants out there but
with certainty as we intensify
production of this crop like any other
crop we grow if we you know have it have
it grown in more fields and have it
grown more intensively with greater
frequency and on any particular field
we're likely to see eventually an
increase in some of our disease problems
so at the at the onset here we're trying
to record everything even some
insignificant little spot on a leaf
we're trying to find out what what
organism causes it you know is they're
super susceptibility in some of our
varieties etc so we're trying to get a
handle on all of that and we're very
interested in collaborating with all of
you a lot more eyes and ears here we
certainly aren't getting to the vast
majority of your of your field so keep
us in mind either through your
Cooperative Extension educator in your
local area and
number of them are here with us today or
contact me or those in my lap we'd be
very interested in that so at this point
where are we we're basically want to
minimize diseases as as a factor in the
production of this crop and since you've
already heard a couple of times we don't
have registered legal available and
efficacious fungicides is one of the
tools at this point I think this will
change over time but we have very good
agronomic practices that we can put in
place we can for starters put a lot of
emphasis on on-site selection you've
heard that the sites on your farm where
you're going to grow the crop we we need
a well-drained site ok Pythium is going
to be a problem and it's not going to be
adapted to every field on your farm we
also know right off the bat that we that
this is a crop that is very susceptible
to white mold fungus the clairtenney of
fungus which is a very wide host range
fungus and this is already a principal
problem for us in this state and growing
crops like dry beans snap beans soybeans
a number of other vegetable crops so we
know that if we have white mold problem
in those other crops it's only going to
lead to a white mold problem in the hemp
if we follow those in rotation so being
aware of not only the hemp and the hemp
varieties but what is the previous
cropping history in the field is very
important you're going to hear in a
little bit here from dr. Alan Taylor
who's going to talk about some of the
pioneering work on looking at efficacy
of different synthetic chemicals and
biological materials for application to
seed to try to get some control of some
of these seed borne and early growth
soil borne microorganisms so I won't say
a lot about that other than to say that
that is a critical issue and probably
where we need pesticides the most is is
getting that seed out of the ground
getting a vigorous initial stand so
hopefully that'll be one of the first
developments in that arena and a good
seedbed is important as well to really
prepare the ground well I don't know how
much if anybody is planting in a no-till
situation right now that has some
probably not too much and that's
probably just as well because that that
has some other complications as well as
far as seed emergence and depending on
what the crop residue from the previous
crop we could be carrying along
pathogens from a previous crop so my
biggest concerns are at the two ends of
the growing season getting that seedling
out of the ground getting it protected
that way and I'm also in our program
we're putting a lot of current emphasis
on the end of the season kind of
problems of diseases and also mycotoxins
one of the things that's nearly
universal that I've seen and looking at
fields is botrytis gray mold and it has
that gray webby growth all over the the
floral parts and whatnot and that's
that's going to be problematic for any
end use you know kind of an anti quality
factor there so we're aware of that I
there there may or may not turn out to
be some varietal differences along that
line hopefully that we could see
something like that but also I know
Chris's group is is doing some work with
some of the same chemicals she's looking
against a powdery mildew interesting and
interested in finding something you
might have efficacy against botrytis as
well I'm concentrating very much on on
the fungi that will colonize the
finished product either the grain the
seed or those buds and what we find is a
predominance of Fusarium fungi and
Fusarium is notorious for producing
mycotoxins and I've spent the better
part of my career working in cereal
crops where the principal problem has
been Fusarium head blight and
contamination of the of the grain with
dioxin a violin also known as vomit
toxin and so it was at least a mile
surprise to me to start looking at
quality and the and the hemp and finding
that though those same problems are very
prevalent there and we're finding a
diversity of Fusarium species
particularly Fusarium gramineae arum
which is the principal problem we have
on corn and small grain cereals which
does in the long term open up the whole
crop rotation question a little bit as
well because the the wisdom would be if
we're having problems with white mold
and we have some commonality with maybe
some of our diseases of vegetables in
some cases that grain crops would be a
great rotation well there's a caveat on
that we have to look at that and I think
that we have to be conscious of how
Fusarium might be building up in the in
the grain crop that precedes the hemp
crop so we have a lot to learn about
that again we may you know get super
lucky and find find a variety or some
genes in particular that would confer
resistance to Fusarium but I wouldn't
hold out a lot of hope on that I've been
working in cereal systems for my fourth
decade now and it is still an elusive
problem genetically we have been able to
basically sort out the super susceptible
varieties and kind of push them to the
side and we have found genetic control
that moderates a you know kind of
intermediate level of resistance and yet
when it rains when the crops flower and
we have the fungus in the air we will
get Fusarium develop and we will have
mycotoxins Jamie may be scared you a
little bit about that one figure about
thirty-six parts per million than that
I'm hoping is an extreme case but we've
been looking at seed Lots from last
couple of years and it's not unusual to
have four or five six parts per million
the FDA guidelines for any human food
product is one part per million okay so
there there will be some effort made to
try to bring things down to that one of
the things that we're actively looking
at in our research program is we're
looking at the possibility of both
organically approved type fungicide
materials bio fungicides as well as more
traditional chemical fungicides and
we're applying that at the outset of
flower
on the crowd we have some experiment
we're doing some timings on that too so
we would like to see what potential that
has in bringing down suppressing the
levels of this deoxy no volatile toxin
in the in the grain or in the in the
buds so that's something we feel is
pretty high priority right now talking
about kind of in the middle of the
growing season we've seen an awful lot
of different things we've seen some of
these vascular wilt disorders haven't
seen a complete wipe out of many fields
of that but we've seen some serious
problems in a couple of cases with with
Pythium root rot that's the that starts
early in the season and progresses into
killing whole plants also the Fusarium
fungus in soils can do that you may have
seen some stray plants in the plots this
morning that showed Fusarium wilt what
we have seen is a whole diversity of
fungal leaf spots and some of them
really very minor you know have to look
a long way in a row and find a couple
spots here and there and a couple of
diseases in particular one we call by
Polaris leaf spot that seems some
connection with varieties as well but it
can be severe blighting of the whole
canopy so we will be looking primarily
at genetic varietal selection in the
future as a means of combating some of
those things and so we look forward to
working together with larry's program
and others here to try to get a better
handle on those things but there the if
you're into Latin names there's a few on
that sheet there they're all kinds of
generative fungi that we have found
associated with these blights and we're
methodically working through proving
they're pathogenicity isolating them in
pure culture inoculating amount of
different varieties of of half in the
greenhouse and seeing to what extent
they are pathogenic another interesting
question is the host range of some of
these pathogenic microbes for instance
we we found some organisms that we
haven't proven yet but very similar
organism found on the weeds nearby in
our home
plots so it could be that weed control
is also important in you know in the
epidemiology of some of these diseases
so we we have a tremendous amount to
learn and we look forward to you being
students along with us and help us to
learn some of these things so are there
some questions or some observations
you'd like to share okay the question
was whether we have found any difference
in susceptibility if you will between
the money's just and dioecious varieties
since we're basically just looking we're
not inoculating anything so there's no
controlled experiments to do that
comparison so we can't definitively
describe that the vast majority of the
varieties in field settings we've seen
before
so far disease is fairly uncommon most
most of the plants of all all types are
looking fair well I won't say resistant
because they may not have been exposed
to the inoculum but I don't have any
general observation on that the line is
there some information anybody's aware
of along that line yeah good
yeah
but I appreciate that observation and we
can we can try to look at that a little
more closer that's that's very helpful
thank you thank you so I just curious if
anybody that's been growing the crop has
had any significant production issue
with disease they don't want to be the
only one so come talk to me privately
thank you
[Applause]
and our last speaker of the afternoon is
dr. Alan Taylor who is a seat scientist
here at Cornell Agrotech and has been
doing some research on seat treatments
and their interaction with soil
pathogens Alan thanks Larry and you can
see quite a number of speakers that we
have today but really I want to say is
as a seed guy to be a part of the
Cornell hemp team has been really
rewarding with this project pathologist
plant breeders a canned ray of people in
their expertise is then Chris and Larry
have really pulled together their
expertise is so we can move together so
so that's been really rewarding so my
program in the area of seed Science and
Technology besides what I'm going to be
talking to you on the seed treatment
project today is we also try to provide
support to their the ongoing project so
we're looking at some of the seed Lots
that are coming in will do the
germination purity to see quality so
we're doing that in conjunction with
with a larger project to kind of move
everything forward and so we all kind of
learn together Tim talked about in his
presentation from Ag and markets about
the big picture going on what's with the
farm bill and really if I go back a year
ago when we started working with the
seed treatments to really pitch this to
this ir4 group which is the national
group which fosters registration for
specialty crops I kind of got hemp is
considered as a specialty crop but that
they would be working on biological and
chemical seed treatments and at that
time just a year ago at this time before
the 2018 farm bill was passed it was all
the industrial hemp CBD hemp was lumped
in with a recreational cannabis so
there's no pesticides were labeled on
this so this is really a void however
there's already very mature materials
and special the chemical seed treatments
that are already there and you use this
to be grow any other crops or even
biological so so really our project was
kind of to pull some of this together
some of these promising materials that
already been used commercially
on other crops to see how they're going
to work on him
I want to thank Gary who just talked
about first of all the need really have
need of getting this crops a direct
seeded crop for an industrial for either
fiber or for grain to get it established
and the seed treatments and how that can
help that also Gary's group have been
very supportive in providing the
pathology support for this project as
well so it's fortunate again getting
back to this ir4 group again that they
their whole purpose is to foster
registration we have what's called their
integrated solutions which is one of
their large programs which has become a
multi regional so we have field studies
they'll be talking about from cornellà
two locations we also have field studies
in the southern region at Virginia Tech
and then also at North Dakota State on
the South Center excuse me the
north-central region though so when we
did this we've use one variety of anko
as a dual purpose variety and inc has
been kind of our white rat that we do
for a lot of our seed quality
investigations good quality seed line to
begin with we've developed my laboratory
I'm kind of working off of this handout
if you haven't the evaluation of seed
treatments on industrial crops for
management of damping off so we have a
laboratory scale seed treatment
equipment my program is pretty unique in
the in the United States for having
small scale equipment that we can
basically simulate what a larger seed
company would be doing I'm treating many
many pounds of seeds we can treat just
an ounce of seed which is fine for most
of our trials so we're able to do that
in-house to do a lot of screening on
what seed treatment binders - some of
the particulars that I'm not going to go
into here but the first thing we want to
do is we're seeing this material we're
looking at biological biological so two
major biocontrol agents is either a
beneficial fungi Trichoderma or a
beneficial bacteria which are bacillus
and then we also had a chemicals
Genta is the only chemical company that
stepped up a year ago so very mature
materials the apron Excel Maxum
materials that are widely registered on
vegetable as well as field crops we also
have biochemical materials in the
chemical group are called phosphites you
know phosphate as a fertilizer but the
phosphates are unique that their
systemic materials but also been shown
in other systems to control Pythium so
we wanted to include that number of
pathogens Pythium just like again gary
kind of set the stage for me to talk
about this the Pythium has kind of been
our our key target pathogen but also
Fusarium and rhizoctonia that can be
there we have a laboratory bioassay that
we screened materials early on just to
look at application rates also if
there's any potential phyto toxicity as
we're playing materials again for the
first time on hemp we don't know what
that seed treatment crop combination is
going to yield so we did all that type
of background information if you're
interested in the data it's on the back
sheet and to try to simplify because
there's there's 15 treatments and rather
to try to go through all this but color
coded this to really kind of simplify
and you can if you don't have it you can
almost see it from here is on the stand
improves here and then we say all these
treatments in blue are the chemical c
treatments that's the apron XL maksim
combination doing very well and you
would expect that they're very well well
developed chemistry's for control the
two black treatments are the non treated
seats so that's our check and then all
these greens are the biological so the
biologicals and in our hands on him is
affording really no appreciable
protection against early season damping
off this is just based on our two field
studies we had the field study conducted
in East Africa and I want to thank Jamie
who just talked to you a few minutes ago
helping coordinate that site and then
the Geneva site that Larry's group was
very supportive in
in us getting that one launched as well
so we're really at the first year with
us at this point in time I'm still
waiting for the data from the Virginia
Tech sites and the North Dakota so we
can start filling this in and again
that's really the purpose of having a
multi-state multi-region project is in
case we have flukes in our data we want
to see what sort of a consistent trends
there would be over the long run we're
in communication now with all the
companies for biological companies the
chemical company things like that so
they are two abreast of this we're going
to be the plans right now would be to
continue this project for a second year
we'll be tweaking some things going back
to kind of a drawing board and looking
at especially these biologicals try to
improve their efficacy to get them to
prove prove better especially using
Pythium as our target pathogen so that's
kind of very quickly in a nutshell kind
of what we found there's any questions
on this or other seed questions yes the
three use a tip um so I use area Minh
Rhizoctonia are kind of a three key that
the pathogen Frankie
saw born pathogens that would be
tackling the city and again when we
focuses that when we had the natural and
festival with Pythium Gary's group did
the characterization of that Pythium for
us so we know what pathogen went what
species that we're dealing with and so
it with it with our tell all tell attest
which is kind of a seed testing
procedure then we can screen things you
know 24/7 and so we can see can what's
going on which treatments are doing well
which ones are not doing well I meant
okay I'll turn this back over Larry so
we can get a deal this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu